it was an unfiltered unabashed and
unrestrained tweet storm
president Trump using Twitter over the
weekend to a sales special counsel
Robert Muller and the Russia probe
saying there was no collusion and no
crime accusing the FBI justice and state
departments of leaking lying in
corruption adding defiantly a total
witch hunt with massive conflicts of
interest
the Muller probe which has netted five
guilty pleas from Trump associates so
far is awash in controversy in part
because of its sprawling nature and as
yet still no evidence of collusion even
as mr. Trump becomes increasingly
bombastic leaders on Capitol Hill
including members of the president's
very own party are warning him and his
attorneys to back off when it comes to
mr. Muller he is following the evidence
where it takes him and I think it's very
important he'd be allowed to do his job
without interference and there are many
Republicans who share my view if you
have an innocent client mr. Dowd act
like it Russia attacked our country
let's special counsel Muller figure that
out the White House is also rejecting
suggestions that the president has
become so frustrated by the
investigation which has expanded to
include documents from the Trump
Organization that he plans to get rid of
the man in charge and House Attorney Ty
Cobb said the president is not
considering or discussing the firing of
Special Counsel Robert Muller the
president's complained that the widening
investigation is a witch-hunt is not new
nor novel in fact it's reminiscent of
what Clinton White House officials said
about the probe led by independent
counsel Ken Starr back in 1998 Starr was
called corrupt his office the source of
too many leaks and then President
Clinton the object of you guessed it a
political witch-hunt
this is the first place I came for the
primaries yet in New Hampshire today the
president looked to get back on message
promoting his administration's effort to
combat opioid abuse calling for stiffer
sanctions against drug dealers including
the death penalty breath the president
today also expanded his legal team
hiring former US Attorney for the
District of Columbia Joe digenova he
previously actually argued that the
president
may have been framed by the DOJ and FBI
I think a bulldog attorney to his team
right